les municipales à montbard c'est
l'histoire d'un face à face inédit car
féminin d'un côté christelle silvestre
l'édile socialiste élu surprise il ya
six ans à la faveur d'une triangulaire
brigue un deuxième mandat de l'autre
laurence porte cette militante udi
proche de françois sauvadet veut faire
basculer à nouveau la ville à droite
opposition de style et de programmes on
a des questions quand même sur le
programme mais on a aussi des questions
sur
la petite navette
nous retrouvons christelle silvestre au
pied des barres hlm du beugnon la maire
sortante imagine déjà ici un écoquartier
fort de 120 nouveaux logements sans
oublier le centre ville qu'elle souhaite
redynamiser en rénovant le marché
couvert autre promesse un quartier
d'entreprises autour de la gare tgv ce
que vraiment je veux faire passer c'est
qu'on a un véritable programme que non
la poser sur la table ce programme on
l'a distribué à tous les habitants on
est allés nous au débat de la jeune
chambre économique pour aller le
défendre et échanger sur les autres
programmes mais malheureusement lawrence
works n'a pas souhaité venir se défendre
sur ces propositions pourtant à quelques
mètres de là laurence porte ne ménage
pas ses piques contre sa rivale la
candidate centriste veut lutter contre
ce qu'elle appelle le gaspillage de
l'argent public dans des projets
pharaoniques
selon elle montbardois cesser de vivre
au dessus de ses moyens les mesures
qu'elle avance affiche ostensiblement
leur modestie le projet phare c'est tout
simplement qu'on se rentre dans une
ville où on est bien où chacun sent
qu'il a sa place dans la commune avec
beaucoup plus de convivialité je donne
un simple exemple qui est celui du parc
buffon qui manque terriblement d'une
signalétique et qu'on souhaiterait aussi
voir davantage réinvesti par les
montbardois ça peut passer par des
choses toutes simples comme refaire à
nouveau du parc buffon l'écrin qui
accueillera la fête nationale du 14
juillet c'est aussi une mini ferme
enfantine c'est avec plein de belles
petites initiatives qu on peut faire de
grandes réalisations au final quelle que
soit la gagnante du scrutin elle aura à
gérer le gros dossier de la dette elle
était monté en flèche au début des
années 2000 sous l'ère d'un ancien maire
ump elle est toujours aujourd'hui
rapporté à chaque montbardois près de
six fois supérieur à la moyenne
nationale
malgré la forte augmentation des impôts
et bien à la fin du mandat la dette
comparativement à celle de semur et
châtillon est maintenant de 4,49 fois
plus importante donc ce qui pèse dans le
sac à dos de nos enfants c'est plus de
20 millions de dette totale on n'a pas
baissé assez ça c'est une réalité on
aurait voulu faire plus mais si on veut
pouvoir faire des choses faire les cons
quartier et puis faire le centre ville
et puis travailler sur l'emploi sur la
ville eh bien il faut que l'on puisse
aussi faire des investissements nous
avons réussi à maîtriser les finances de
la ville et sa salle embête beaucoup
parce qu'elle ne comprend pas tout sur
le domaine financier petite égratignure
à sa concurrente mais christelle
silvestre doit aussi essuyé son lot de
critiques depuis la défection de son
ancien premier adjoint il ya trois mois
jean bonne amie a démissionné en jugeant
qu'elle n'avait pas su endosser les
habits de mer laurence porte n'oublie
jamais de reprendre ses paroles à son
compte